before I send boxes over I have to take
all of my things out these boxes were
interspersed with all sorts of things
golf shirts clothing pants shoes there
were many things I would say much more
not that I know of so it's hard not to
laugh when Trump is talking about his
golf shirts and his shoes that he had to
take out before sending the boxes back
from Nara but I think that the key
takeaway from the entire statement here
is that he does admit to taking the
documents he admits that he was in
contact with Nera about sending them
back and his defense was essentially
that he was too busy didn't have time to
get around to it even though he was
subpoenaed in this case and once you
receive a subpoena you're supposed to
realize oh this is actually serious if
the fact that you were in contact with
authorities before the subpoena wasn't
enough of a message to take this thing
seriously The subpoena should have done
it for you